[Musik]
hallo herr tsitos als heute jetzt ein
richtig schnelles und sehr leckeres ofen
oder sex mit spargel ich werde den
spargel wie gesagt im ofen zu behalten
dafür nämlich grünen spargel und dazu
gibt's kartoffeln und einen leckeren
joghurt dip das ganze geht ziemlich
schnell
er braucht nur wenige flughafen und wenn
die kartoffeln und frühen spargels und
da habt habt ihr schon fast alles ich
zeige euch mal eben dafür brauche ich
einen esslöffel olivenöl 500 gramm
kleinen stoffel habe ich noch salz und
pfeffer für den joghurt dip brauche ich
200 gramm joghurt das ist in 35
prozentiger naturjoghurt etwas pfeffer
ich habe ich 40 gramm getrocknete
tomaten in pavilly kompletter eine um
handelte zitrone und etwa 100 gramm käse
dann nämlich jetzt einweiht käse aus
kuhmilch und ich hab hier noch 500 gramm
spargel da nämlich den grünen speidel
salz pfeffer und einer prise pop findet
zuerst einmal die kartoffeln zu bereiten
da können wir jetzt entweder so ganz
kleine kartoffel nehmen diese dinge zum
beispiel oder ihr nehmt einfach solche
kartoffeln ich werde sie mit schale
verwenden deswegen habe ich jetzt auch
schöne zeit abgewaschen ohne mir wenn
die drillinge die ganz kleinen blickt
lieber gewesen aber der mourad meghni
gebracht also verarbeitet geht weiter
und die scheide ich jetzt einfach
entscheidung auch richtig hübsch aus
[Musik]
die kommen jetzt auch einfach lässt habe
ich eine back folie drauf und dafür
möchte ich die kartoffeln jetzt mit dem
olivenöl mit salz und pfeffer
[Musik]
so kommt noch einmal in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 190 grad heißluft ihr könnt
auch ober unterhitze nehmen dann auf 210
grad und dann für etwa 25 minuten
und die zwischenzeit mit sich natürlich
um den rest vorzubereiten
als nächstes bereit ist jetzt wie
joghurt soße zu dafür habe ich den
joghurt tomaten jetzt 5 1 hatten
und da nehme ich immer gern getrocknete
tomaten die in öl eingelegt sind falls
ihr nur getrocknete tomaten nimmt ohne
öl solltet ihr die auf jeden fall vorher
mithalten macher übergeht und damit sie
wieder schön reich werden nämlich
meistens ein bisschen hart
[Musik]
die kommission mit reifen tomaten dann
auch der käse den wir jetzt einfach
unter
dann ein bisschen zitronenschalen
abseits
und natürlich auch mit pfeffer würzen
sein schrieb ich jetzt keine situation
in der käse ist schon richtig salzig und
passt dann wirklich gut zu dem neutralen
joghurt wird das ganze durch gerührt
[Musik]
den joghurt bis jetzt schon mal um in
das glas schelte da möchte ich später
auch reservieren da kommt jetzt gleich
noch das fein gehackte wie kommt rüber
[Musik]
der grüne spargel setzt normalerweise
eigentlich gar nicht geschält werden
außerdem dienten sind häufig sind schon
immer unberechtigt ende erst mal ab aber
das ist eigentlich holz ist das heißt
sich neben den und schneiden einmal so
ein bisschen diagonal über
[Musik]
zum spargel gebe ich jetzt noch salz
pfeffer und den zucker dazu und mario
matt und dann muss ich im prinzip nur
noch auf die kartoffeln im ofen warten
sie brauchen jetzt noch ein bisschen und
dann kommt der spargel damit rein und
der zehn minuten weiter gegangen
das war's dann auch schon
[Musik]
erstens das essen fertig ist heute kein
fleisch zu produzieren
vor allem weil ich mal erspart
ich liebe sparkurs auch gegrillt einfach
auf den server nichts machen einfach aus
und es wird wirklich mega und dass man
mir diese leute wo soll gerne fleisch
verzichten möchten genial
grüner spargel es spargel geht echt
immer christa darin ihre tomaten
basilikum der gipfel machen dass in
sachen von der absoluten weg in diese
kombination nicht am morgen mit den
kartoffeln dass mit dieser schönen
kleinen runden aber ich habe es mir
[Musik]
vielleicht aber manche haben es schon
herausgefunden
schmeckt dann freut mich das
vor allem ist ein cooles vor gericht ich
finde es einfach sommer vorbei ist
einfach sehr locker und leicht schmeckt
und wickelt man kann doch das essen
nun eigentlich schon fast kalt aber ich
jetzt gut abkühlen lassen
wer egal ich bin das konzept auch genial
und falls ihr es nach mittenwald - doch
das noch mal für euch und ich wünsche
euch gerne nachmachen absteigen will
mehr ich glaube ich auch jeden tag
[Musik]